до повномасштабного вторгнення РФ
Наталія сіромаха Жила і працювала в
Харкові там досі залишаються її колеги
програмісти і розробники програмного
забезпечення
через війну Наталія перебралася до
польського Кракова і тепер працює
дистанційно щодня перед роботою жінка
зв'язується з колегами з України аби
дізнатися як у них справи
віолки
Ми всі намагаємося викладатися на повну
ми розуміємо що повинні працювати не
покладаючи рук щоб досягати успіху і
підтримувати свою державу
хочу показати вам нашого кращого друга
цими днями
але працює генератор працює стерлінк
у нас усіх також була можливість прийти
в офіс підзарядити наші пристрої тож я
би сказав що ми анітрохи не втратили в
продуктивності
є деякі проблеми з електрикою і водою в
Києві наприклад у мене вдома але в офісі
проблем немає тому сьогодні І
напередодні всі прийшли в офіс
тут і світло і кава є тож ми працюємо ми
незламній сильні Як і всі українці
так Харків виглядав На початку березня
Невдовзі після перших російських
обстрілів чимало районів міста досі без
світла і мобільного зв’язку деякі
співробітники телекомунікаційних
компаній працюють за кордону але роблять
усе можливе аби люди у Харкові мали
зв'язок та
інтернетство основна проблема В нас на
сьогоднішній день це електрика і
стільниковий зв'язок не завжди буває
зв'язок з нашими співробітниками тому що
більшість людей працюють у Харкові і не
завжди з ними можна зв'язатися
[музика]
Алла стручова нині у Польщі але три чи
приїжджала до Харкова щоб допомагати
[музика]
під час своєї першої поїздки жінка
побачила що росіяни зробили з її
будинком це відео зняте в травні
цьогоріч в оселі але на околиці Харкова
[музика]
жінка повернулася ще раз за кілька
місяців тоді російські війська вже
відступили від Харкова
Утім від будинку Алли залишилося саме
згарище
[музика]
її колеги нині мають чимало роботи треба
лагодити пошкоджені інтернет-кабелі
через відсутність електрики часто
працюють у темряві зі звичайними
ліхтариками Інтернет - це зв’язок із
зовнішнім світом для жителів Харкова і
компанія які працюють у місті доступ до
мережі критично важливий
захисні казки і бронежилети тепер стали
для майстрів невід'ємним елементом
спорядження
до війни it-сектор в Україні процвітав у
галузі працювали понад 250 тисяч осіб
навіть цього року попри війну експорт
комп'ютерних послуг за 10 місяців зріс
на 10%, порівняно з попереднім роком
українські лікарні одні з тих хто
регулярно отримує допомогу від
it-сектора
Ми багато інвестуємо і передаємо гроші
на захист нашої держави у Харкові
айтішники задинатили більше мільярда
гривень йому Продовжуємо Це робити
у Кракові розробниця програмного
забезпечення Наталія сіромаха знайшла
житло її діти ходять до місцевої школи і
вивчають польську мову
Утім Вони досі почуваються біженцями
от син не виказував Багато емоцій Я
бачила як він у мить подорослішав для
доньки Це був великий стрес вона весь
час спитала чому чому Що ми зробили
поганого чому я все втратила Чому мої
друзі більше не поруч
ми всі нині наче равлики у равлика
завжди з собою його дім просто на спині
у нас завжди з собою частинка України
Харкова у мене Вона завжди при собі Хоча
я тут у Польщі думками я у харкові я
досі в Україні
[музика]